- [Protesters] Take off your riot gear!
We don't see no riot here!
Take off your riot gear!
- [Reporter] This protest
in Seattle, Washington
on June 1st looks to be contained,
but, in a split second,
everything unravels.
(protesters screaming)
(tear gas explodes)
Since the killing of George Floyd,
police departments across the country
are facing increased
scrutiny over their tactics.
(protesters shouting)
- [Man] Keep the line, keep the line.
- [Reporter] This incident
in Seattle's Capitol Hill neighborhood
is under investigation by
the police department's
internal watchdog group for
the use of pepper spray,
blast balls and tear
gas to disperse a crowd.
(tear gas explodes)
The Wall Street Journal analyzed
over two hours of footage
shot by multiple witnesses as
well as police scanner audio
from the scene to examine how
police and protester tactics
pushed the incident into chaos.
- [Protesters] Black lives matter!
Black lives matter!
- [Reporter] An hour
after a citywide curfew,
about 2,000 people are
headed east on Pine Street
toward the Seattle Police
East Precinct to protest.
(Protestors protesting)
- [Reporter] But Seattle P.D. quickly
erect a barrier one block away.
- [Policeman] The precinct's
pretty well cut off.
- [Reporter] The scene
still seems under control.
The precinct captain even listens
in response to protestor demands.
- [Protestors] Let us through!
Let us through!
- [Reporter] The tone changes
when an organizer warns
that some people have
other tactics in mind.
- [Organizer] They're gonna try
and push through these gates
and we're all gonna get hurt.
- [Protestors] Let us walk!
Let us walk!
- [Policeman] We have a group
that pushed on the fence line
and threw one bottle.
At this point, they're loud
but we're under control.
- [Reporter] Then, a crucial
change in place tactics.
They swap the line of bike officers
for officers in riot gear.
They also discuss using pepper spray,
what they referred to as OC,
short for oleoresin capsicum.
- [Policeman] We're not going
to let them push on the line
because it creates an officer safety risk.
If we get another significant push,
we'll deploy OC.
- [Reporter] Then, a change in
tactics from some protestors.
A few at the front begin raising umbrellas
which protestors frequently use
to shield themselves from
pepper spray and tear gas.
- [Policeman] We have several
people deploying umbrellas
believed to be a deterrent.
- [Reporter] Police
experts we spoke with note
that umbrellas are often seen as a hazard
because they block sight lines.
Then, the pivotal moment.
A person in front is holding an umbrella
that extends past the barricade.
An officer reaches out attempting
to push it out of the way.
(suspenseful music)
The officer grabs the umbrella
and the person tries to hold on.
(suspenseful music)
At the same time,
another officer deploys pepper spray
at the direction of the
incident commander or IC.
- [Policeman] We're deploying
OC at the direction of the IC.
(suspenseful music)
- [Reporter] Other officers follow suite,
spraying as the crowd backs away.
Some on the crowd throw
objects toward the police line.
(suspenseful music)
Then, the order to deploy blast balls
and CS or tear gas.
- [Policeman] Squad,
go ahead and deploy CS,
blast balls and CS.
(tear gas explodes)
- [Reporter] Most of the
protestors have dispersed
at this point but a few
remain close to the barrier
despite tear gas filling the air.
(protestor wheezes)
(suspenseful music)
Seattle Police Department policy dictates
that once a crowd poses an
imminent risk to public safety
or property destruction,
police should give an order to disperse.
The policy also states officers
will not use blast balls
until a dispersal order has been issued.
(tear gas explodes)
Footage we reviewed didn't show officers
giving a verbal order.
(suspenseful music)
The Seattle Police
Department said the incident
is still under investigation.
Police declare the June 1st protest a riot
because some people in the
crowd threw objects at police.
11 people were arrested
according to Seattle Police.
12 people required medical
attention, including police
and members of the public.